Nicholas Burns was US ambassador to NATO
and Undersecretary of State for
political affairs under president george
w bush he's now a professor at Harvard's
Kennedy School of Government
good morning mr. ambassador let me ask
you this question
yeah on the one hand this is a major
breakthrough on the other hand as Holly
mentioned North Korea's renege before
former secretary gates a defense
secretary said I'm tired of buying the
same horse twice when talking about
North Korea
so where do you see this recent move you
know I think you have to say in a way
John it's positive that the President
and Kim jong-un are turning toward
diplomacy we were on a collision course
with North Korea there was a possibility
of a war with unpredictable and
potentially catastrophic consequences so
if if there's going to be a period of
the next two or three or four months of
diplomacy
I think that's positive the problem is
this is a big gamble because as you've
been seeing the North Koreans under
violated their agreement with President
Clinton violated their agreement with
President George W Bush I was in both
administrations and saw that happen Kim
jong-un is in a very strong position he
has nuclear weapons
he's made progress on his ballistic
missile and nuclear test he's just about
maybe on the verge of having the
capacity to achieve a nuclear weapon
that could hit the United States so what
are his motives here he wants legitimacy
his father and grandfather did not meet
with an American president going all the
way back to the 1940s he wants
legitimacy he wants sanctions relief I
think he'll chill he'll be open maybe to
negotiating some transparency about his
nuclear weapons I don't think he'll give
them up so for the president our
president this is gonna be about as
difficult as it gets and a major gamble
there's an interesting piece by Victor
cha this morning in the New York Times
it says actually that gamble which you
talked about that this could actually
bring the two countries to the brink of
war if there is failure in these talks
play that scenario out well normally
what we do here Nora is any any prior
American government you start with lower
level talks the secretary and higher
level the Secretary of State would be
involved you'd really want to test
whether the North Koreans are serious
whether they're willing to dismantle
their nuclear program before the
president gets into a room with a
historic room meeting with the North
Korean leadership if President Trump and
Kim jong-un fail in their summit efforts
there's really nowhere else to go that
thing could drive us back towards
thinking about a military option to stop
the North Koreans from developing a
nuclear weapon that can hit the United
States so that's where the gamble is and
there's no track record here kim
jung-han hasn't met with a Chinese
leadership he's not met with a South
Korean leader much less the American
leader and as you know the president
doesn't have a deep bench of advisors
the top negotiator is leaving we don't
have an ambassador to South Korea how
concerned are you about that void and
I'm being completely serious here could
we see Dennis Rodman even coming in and
advising the president about this
upcoming meeting well this is very
serious the State Department has been
dismantled
you have no American ambassador in Seoul
no North Korean expert our greatest
expert just left last week so you don't
have a bench you don't have the talent
that where you'd normally have because
President Trump has forsaken the State
Department all right Nicholas Burns
always good to have you thank you so
much for joining thank you